leiser geworden ist diese kritik wenn
man auf die oppositionsfraktionen hier
schaut auf alle oppositionsfraktionen
ganz im gegenteil das sieht man allein
daran dass heute zu dieser zweiter und
dritter lesung des gesetzentwurfes
zahlreiche änderungsanträge vorliegen
die im anschluss dann auch namentlich
abgestimmt werden sollen und dieser
kritik die bäume natürlich auch heute
bevor es im plenarsaal losgeht nachgehen
mit meinen beiden gästen und ich freue
mich dass sie zu mir gekommen sind als
phönix begrüße ganz herzlich wolfgang
kubicki für die fdp-fraktion
bundestags-vizepräsident aber hier auch
vor allem in seiner funktion als
stellvertretender fdp-vorsitzender und
thorsten frei darf ich ganz herzlich
begrüßen für die cdu csu fraktion erst
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende und hat in den
letzten tagen gerade was die
verhandlungen zwischen spd und cdu csu
anbelangt über diesen gesetzentwurf
einiges zu tun gehabt darüber wird man
natürlich sprechen er frei bevor wir
über die ganzen änderungen in der tat
die jetzt noch reingekommen ist in
diesem gesetzentwurf reden ist es
eigentlich erstaunlich dass ich etwas
gar nicht verändert hat nämlich dass die
sieben tage incidents nach wie vor der
einzige messwert sein soll für alle
beschränkungen für schulschließung für
die ausgangssperren für das was ich in
meiner freizeit für die kontaktsperre es
gab daran wahnsinnig viel kritik man hat
gesagt das hat sich der sieben tage
index das ist eigentlich los gekoppelt
von der gesundheitlichen entwicklung
warum hat man nicht die anzahl der
belegten intensivbetten oder der faktor
mit hineingenommen als
bemessungsgrundlage für diese
grundrechts einschränkungen ja da muss
man differenzieren als wir den
paragrafen 28 gemacht haben da haben wir
genau darauf gesetzt einen mix aus
sieben tages incidents aus impfquote
erwert und andere mehr
da sind jeweils rechtsverordnungen der
länder zwischengeschaltet jetzt machen
wir ein gesetz das unmittelbar gilt wenn
die tatbestandsvoraussetzungen gegeben
sind und dafür braucht man einen
einfachen wert die bürger müssen wissen
jetzt sieben tages incidents über 100
jetzt gelten die vorschriften dieses
gesetzes das muss also für jeden bürger
klar sein und deswegen kommt drauf an
einfach und klar zu agieren und es wird
für die nächsten acht bis zehn wochen
auch richtig sein weil die sieben tages
incidents eben letztlich auch ein
surrogat ist ausfielen
anderen bestandteilen es ist also ein
guter frühindikator gestern gerade war
das intensivbetten register ist gerade
ein jahr alt geworden sozusagen und ich
habe es noch nicht ganz verstanden also
konnte man nicht die intensivbetten
auslastung danach schauen wir ja die
ganze zeit warum sagen sie es vielleicht
nochmal etwas verständlicher warum haben
sie das nicht mit reingenommen wir
machen eine notbremse eine bundes
notbremse für hohe inzidenz in über 100
in den letzten sieben tagen
und wenn sie jetzt zu grunde legen
würden die auslastung der intensivbetten
dann ist es viel zu spät dann sind die
patienten in den krankenhäusern dann
werden sie beatmet dann ist es für
politische steuerung viel zu spät und
deswegen ist das der richtige
ansatzpunkt
herr kubicki fdp hatte angekündigt wenn
diese messgröße nämlich dass die
alleinige instruments ausschlaggebend es
dann würde man nicht nur dem
gesetzentwurf nicht zustimmen sondern
sogar verfassungsklage einreichen also
wann werden sie denn jetzt klagen weil
das wird jetzt nicht mehr verändert
nicht nur deswegen sondern auch aus
anderen gründen vielleicht noch aber wir
werden das unmittelbar nach verkündung
tun ich selbst hier wären das nicht als
fraktion machen sondern einzelne
betroffene haben sich selbst auch nach
karlsruhe gehen sie sprechen das
richtigerweise an wenn das
bundesgesundheitsministerium mir
schriftlich bestätigt dass die instanz
keine aussagekraft zum pandemischen
geschehen hat dann kann es keinen wert
sein der automatisch dazu führt dass
grundrechts einschränkungen vorgenommen
werden müssen
denken sie alle drüber nach über ostern
hieß es wir dürfen dem der inzidenz
nicht trauen weil zu wenig getestet
worden seid so wenig gemeldet worden
soll schon daran können sie sehen es ist
einfach rechtlich nicht zulässig bei
einem wert der willkürlich gegriffen
werden kann
grundrechts einschränkungen unmittelbar
gesetzlich anzuordnen bei aller kritik
für werden noch mehr kritik von ihnen
hören ja ne ist schon konzert ich
konzentriere mich auf drei dinge ja
immer trotzdem möchte ich sie zu beginn
fragen gibt es nicht auch gründe die sie
nachdenklich machen diesem gedacht
dieses gesetz doch in der tat sinn macht
vielleicht bei aller kritik der chef der
präsident der intensiv und
notfallmedizin hat gestern in einem sehr
eindringlichen appell
noch mal gefordert an die politischen
verantwortlichen direkt das sind auch
sie den notfallmediziner zu helfen er
hat wirklich gesagt bitte helfen sie uns
beschließen sie morgen das
infektionsschutzgesetz macht sie das
nicht nachdenklich
nein weil ja der eindruck erweckt wird
wenn wir diese maßnahmen nicht
beschließen deutschen bundestag dann
sollen wir in einem rechtsfreien raum
mehr freiheit angesprochen alle länder
haben bewohner verordnungen alle
maßnahmen jetzt das gesetz vorschreibt
können bereits erlassen werden und sind
in verschiedenen ländern ja auch schon
bereits bestandteil der verordnungsgeber
vorpommern baden württemberg
beispielsweise das was uns stört was
mich stört ist die tatsache dass es
flächendeckend über den kamm geschoren
wird denn ich höre auch von der
deutschen gesellschaft für krankenhaus
dass die behauptungen die
intensivstation seien vollständig
überlastet falsch ich kann schleswig
holstein bei uns in lauffen
intensivstationen gerade leer und es mag
an einigen punkten probleme geben das
hatten wir eine erste welle auch er hat
uns leistung sind fast 5000 betten aber
das ist aber dass deutschlandweit ja
auch da muss man sagen nicht wir hatten
in der ersten wieder deutlich mehr
betten und auch deutlich mehr
möglichkeiten es kann zu spannungen in
einzelnen fällen kommen aber das ist
deutschlandweit vor einem kollaps das
gesundheitswesen stehen ist völliger
unsinn ich kann mich das vor drei wochen
noch das erklärt hatte wir waren 300 der
institute zur kommunion das ist nicht
der fall die instanzen sinken langsam
wieder
und nochmal ich komme aus einem
bundesland mit einer inzidenz von jetzt
aktuell 71 man kann nur sagen wir hätten
uns gewünscht dass diese regelung auf
bundesebene die in keiner braucht wie
die minister presseerklärung dass diese
nicht übers knie gebrochen aber die
regelungen gelten ja für
schleswig-holstein dann gar nicht weil
sie ja erst einmal einer inzidenz von
100 gelten das wollen wir noch mal zur
erklärung sie wissen es natürlich aber
hin zu schicken
die haben wir haben auch einen kreis bad
homburg programms über 100 jahren wo wir
genau sagen können wo es herkommt und
ist auch eine spannende frage dass sie
im kreis nicht differenzieren können
dass sie bei einem kreis in einem ort
eine riesen aus bosnien sagten
kreisnamen liegen müssen statt sich auf
den ort zu konzentrieren auch dies ist
unverhältnismäßig
frey wir wollen auf die ausgangssperre
schauen das ist sicher einer der punkte
der am meisten kritik hervorgerufen hat
die bleiben drinnen aber es wird jetzt
etwas sanfter angeblich und zwar die
ausgangssperre soll nicht mehr ab 21 uhr
die nächtliche sondern ab 22 uhr gelten
was um gottes willen ist dann
verfassungsgemäße an dieser
ausgangssperre
ich wüsste nicht dass eine
ausgangssperre nicht verfassungsgemäß
wäre der kritikpunkt untergang der
oppositions stimmen
deswegen heißt es ja noch lange nicht
dass es nicht verfassungsgemäß ist wir
haben obergerichtliche
verwaltungsgerichts entscheidungen zu
diesem thema die haben sich allerdings
mit ganz anderen werten
auseinandergesetzt beispielsweise der
vgh baden württemberg in der situation
wo bei einer landesweiten inzidenz von
über 50 eine ausgangssperre in allen
landkreisen gegolten hat unabhängig
davon wie die örtliche instanz ist das
ist sicherlich nicht verhältnismäßig
entschuldigung diese stunde unterschied
also warum hat man jetzt statt eines
über 22 euro
man muss natürlich immer auch schauen
dass man einerseits epidemiologisch
wirksam ist aber zum anderen auch eine
hohe akzeptanz in der bevölkerung
erreicht und die regelung die wir jetzt
im gesetz haben die ist natürlich gerade
in der sommerzeit deutlich lebensnäher
und deswegen hat sie nicht die gleich
große epidemiologische wirkung aber sie
ist besser als wenn man es nicht macht
und lassen sie mich zuletzt sagen es
gibt kein land in europa dass eine welle
eine pandemie welle brechen konnte ohne
auch auf eine ausgangssperre zu setzen
und zwar teilweise sehr viel rigider als
wir das machen wenn sie auf frankreich
aus spanien auf portugal schauen da hat
man teilweise ganztägige ausgangssperren
gehabt wo die menschen lediglich zum
einkauf von lebensmitteln ihre wohnung
verlassen durften das ist eine ganz
andere situation als das was wir hier in
deutschland
ich weiß dass sie dazu passen so viele
studien wie karl lauterbach gelesen
haben in der tat wenn man jetzt aber von
der studienlage die nicht eindeutig ist
man findet für beide seiten studien
wenn sie jetzt aber sehen in der tat ich
habe die wortmeldung von vielen
medizinern im ohr es ist das
maßnahmenbündel was zählt auch wenn man
vielleicht für die einzelne maßnahme das
mich nachweisen kann also ist
sda nicht vertretbar ausgangssperren das
gesetz gilt ja nur bis zum 30 juni erst
mal im moment vorzusehen über 100 nein
weil die verfassung gilt auch in der
pandemie und einfach zu sagen wir lassen
jetzt mal fünf gerade sein ist in einem
rechtsstaat schlicht und ergreifend
nicht hinnehmen wir werden das zu
erklären es stimmt was er frei sein
ausgangssperren haben eine wirkung in
spanien portugal in großbritannien aber
nur wenn sie tagsüber anordnen und wenn
sie gleichzeitig betriebe schließen
schulen und hochschulen diesen genau das
macht die koalition nicht das was er hat
einen lock down nennen eine isolierte
nächtliche ausgangssperre hat keine
wirkung und je weniger zeit sie haben
ist es ja von den gutachtern auch im
business als auch schon mitgeteilt
worden dass wenn wir das weiter
verschieben die zeitphase mitternacht
bis 5 uhr morgens sind nur wenige
menschen davon betroffen werden dann
wird sich unverhältnismäßig weil sie es
ein paar nämlich geschehe nichts mehr
beitragen können also bei dem punkt
wären wir nicht zusammenkommen glaube
ich zumindest die beiden nicht gleich
wenn ich habe 23 uhr aus dem plenarsaal
des deutschen bundestages nach hause
ging in meiner frau und meiner frau und
mir lieber spazieren gehen wir soll das
verboten sein das kann doch nicht
ernsthaft von der großen koalition
angenommen
also es ist natürlich so dass es immer
noch eine wirkung hat wissenschaftler
gehen davon aus dass man den rwe hat
etwa um 0,2 reduzieren kann
wir müssen insgesamt zu einem wert von
unter 1 kommen und dafür ist das
maßnahmenbündel da da ist es ein
bestandteil und es ist auch ein
notwendiger bestandteil um die nächsten
wenigen wochen überstehen zu können
wir werden schauen was die klagen auch
die freien wähler beispielsweise haben
schon eine klage gegen das gesetz
angekündigt wir wollen noch mal schauen
auf die schulen das auch ein großes
thema bei vielen bürgern und bürgerinnen
es gibt einen erklärungsbedürftigen
grenzwert herr frei der da jetzt rein
gekommen ist eigentlich sollten die
schulen komplett schließen ab einer
inzidenz von 200 über sieben tage jetzt
die zahl ist nicht gewürfelt das würde
ich gleich vorweg nehmen das war
zufälligerweise am montag der
bundesweite durchschnitt der inzidenz
als sich cdu und spd geeinigt haben wenn
sie sich jetzt heute geeinigt haben
werde der grenzwert für die schulen 160
war heute ist die instanz und
tatsächlich also das klingt ein bisschen
willkürlich nein es ist ein kompromiss
es ist ein kompromiss das muss man ganz
offen sagen wir hätten uns was anderes
gewünscht
aus meiner sicht wäre es
unverantwortlich gewesen bei den schulen
erst bei einer inzidenz von 200 in den
distanz unterricht zu gehen
wir hätten uns im grunde genommen
gewünscht dass das ab einer hunderter
inzidenz schon passiert das war in der
koalition nicht erreichbar deswegen
schließt man kompromisse nicht nur bei
diesem punkt sondern auch bei vielen
anderen weil für uns am ende
entscheidend war dass der mix der
maßnahmen einerseits wirksam
andererseits akzeptabel für die menschen
ist und deswegen ist es ein kompromiss
man kann es nicht anders formulieren
wäre eher niedriger wäre er besser
die fdp hat nicht viel übrig für portale
schulschließung ihre parteikollegin
katja suding hat gesagt man kann ja
jetzt auch mehr nach draußen gehen in
parks oder auch in den schulhof aber das
ist ja kein konzept was bis zu den
sommerferien tragen dort also es gibt
verschiedene andere ansätze beispiel sei
die tatsache dass wir in vielen ländern
bereits umgesetzt haben dass in schulen
nur kinder hinein dürfen die schnell
getestete getestet sind also was wir uns
anschauen müssen ist john key incidents
nach dem kreis allgemein seien die
inzidenz in den jahrgängen die in die
schule sollen und in die kita sollen und
mehr wird dort testen desto weniger
wahrscheinlich ist das
infektionsgeschehen in die schulen
hinein getragen wird und aus den schulen
herauskommt das video ist auch für
betriebe ich wenn das ausdrücklich sagen
anzuordnen dass die arbeitgeber einen
test zur verfügung stellen müssen ist
schön aber an sich müssen wir den test
verpflichten waren für arbeitnehmer die
in büros oder in bergheim gehen müssen
weil wir nur auf die art und weise die
symptomen losen infizierten
herausfiltern können die ihr das
einschränkungen ja auch bereichern
herr kubicki es gibt noch einen punkt
der noch zu der bundes notbremse mit ins
gesetz geschrieben worden ist nämlich
dass der bund eigene verordnung erlassen
darf da muss der bundestag jetzt
zustimmen aber trotzdem ist es doch so
eine art blankoscheck damit der bund im
prinzip noch weitere
grundrechtseingriffe die noch nicht
definiert sind vornehmen kann wie stehen
sie zu dieser verordnungs möglichkeit
zunächst einmal ist das rechtlich
zulässig steht dazu bei sehr kritisch
weil die wesentlichen punkte wie er im
gesetz hätten regeln können nach wie vor
regeln könnten beispielsweise die frage
dürfen wir geimpfte und genesene von
denen keine gefahr mehr ausgeht genauso
wie wir behandeln wie diejenigen
möglichen funktionsträger sein können
ein ganz großer punkt der wird die große
koalition ein kreis vor noch massiv
beschäftigen infektionsschutz ist
gefahrenabwehr und von menschen keine
gefahr mehr ausgehen kann
dann können sie auch nicht mit gefahr
habe der maßnahmen belegt werden und das
wächst ja jeden tag haben jeden tag mehr
geimpfte jeden tag mehr menschen nicht
infektionsträger sein können und deshalb
wenn die auch in den entsprechenden
maßnahmen unterworfen werden muss dass
offensichtlich falsch sein
herr frei tut mir leid wir müssen
reingeben der bundestagspräsident
wolfgang schäuble hat in saal schon
betreten wir werden noch mehr argumente
in der aussprache gleich hören thorsten
frei für die cdu herzlichen dank und
wolfgang kubicki für die fdp dass sie
hierher gekommen sind und wir schauen
ganz schnell den saal der
bundestagspräsident hat die sitzung
gerade eröffnet